So Last Friday, the progressive website Mother
Jones included me in an article about a quote
"new extremist media industry that is further
to the right than Breitbart."
In the piece, the author referred to me as
"far right", citing interviews I've done with
Mike Cernovich, Milo Yiannopoulos and Lauren
Southern to back up his accusation.
He cherry picked these guests to fit his narrative,
yet somehow missing the endless amount of
liberals I've had on and the progressives
I've hosted, including Margaret Cho, Hillary
Rosen, Mark Duplass, John Fugelsang and Michael
Ian Black.
The article also attacked Patreon, the crowdfunding
platform of which myself and my team's livelihood
depends on, for being tolerant of people with
far right views such as mine, though of course,
nowhere did it include any of my purported
"far right" views.
Earlier in the week, Forbes called The Rubin
Report a "conservative talk show", but immediately
retracted the statement when I contacted them.
Ironically, I've been saying for awhile defending
my liberal beliefs is becoming a conservative
position.
Although I don't think being called a conservative
is somehow bad, it clearly isn't a proper
descriptor for this show in which I've hosted
people from across the political divide.
For Mother Jones to accuse me of being an
extremist, further to the right of Breitbart,
is obviously an inflammatory and demonstrably
dishonest statement.
I've been around many people who over the
last few years have been unfairly maligned,
and I'm all to familiar with how this all
goes.
Whether it's Sam Harris, Jordan Petersen,
Colin Moriarty or Brett Weinstein -- each
attack is virtually never based on what these
people have said, but are instead crafted
out of straw man arguments with the words
racist and bigot tossed around like candy.
Suddenly, the onus is on people who aren't
racists or bigots to disprove this accusation,
usually slung by a misguided celebrity, or
a malicious newspaper or website.
The move, then, is on the accused -- should
they spend time and energy defending themselves
from accusations which aren't true, only to
bring more attention to the accusations themselves?
Or should they ignore ignore them, hoping
the false claims will go away over time.
I think there are solid arguments to be made
for either tactic, and it truly depends on
the situation at hand and the person involved.
In this case, though, I went on the attack.
I decided this case was too egregious to ignore,
contacting the article's author via Twitter,
screenshotting pieces of his article and asking
him to defend them.
Of course, he couldn't defend his own words...that's
the thing with truth, it's hard to work around...and
eventually he made slight changes to the article,
like including a tweet of mine in which I
defended myself from his claims, and he removing
the word "far" in front of the word "right"
before referencing me in the article.
Putting aside the specifics of this article
itself, I was happy to get a strong defense
in public from many friends all over the political
map.
People like Joe Rogan, Colin Moriarty, Faisal
Saeed al Mutar, Bret Weinstein, Eric Weinstein,
Michael Shermer, Peter Boghossian and many
others offered strong defenses of me, just
as I've offered for others when I've seen
them unfairly attacked.
I even got a public defense from Donald Trump
Jr.
Putting my friends and public allies aside
though, it's incredibly inspiring and humbling
to see literally 10's of thousands of people
offer their voice when they feel you've been
unjustly attacked.
And that's the key to this whole thing.
It's not me, or Sam, or Jordan or Bret that
they fear, what they really fear is that all
of you will starting saying what you think
... because There's strength in numbers.
By Monday, I wanted to put the whole story
behind me.
My dog has a health emergency, which helped
put everything in perspective, but I admit,
I did get sucked back into the attack very
briefly.
Over the course of a Twitter exchange, I got
the writer of the piece, Josh Harkinson, to
publicly admit I am NOT further right than
Breitbart, though of course, he didn't change
the title or have Mother Jones issue any sort
of public correction.
One other interesting piece to all this, is
that the writer, John Harkinson, is one of
the 40 people that James Hodgkinson, the shooter
of the Republican baseball team last week,
followed on Twitter.
Now I can't draw a direct link there, but
we know that Hodgkinson was a far lefty who
obviously was driven to political extremes.
So, when this very same writer does a hatchet
job on me calling me further right than Breitbart,
which is clearly code for racist, I cannot
sit back there and take it.
This is exactly why I've been saying you can't
punch Nazi's.
Call everyone you oppose a Nazi and a racist
and then eventually you will see violence
as the next logical step.
It's not a crazy exercise to think that this
is partially what drove James Hodgkinson.
In hindsight his attack on me was the next
obvious step in where this whole collectivist
movement is going.
I've talked for a long time about how if you
can't debate ideas, you use lies and buzzwords.
Having it turned on me shouldn't have been
a surprise, especially from a Leftist site
like Mother Jones, yet it still did surprise
me somehow.
Make no mistake, there is a Thinkquisition
going on here, and it can come for anyone
at any time.
If you ally yourself with people who value
the movement, in this case a political one,
over you as an individual, then eventually
it is inevitable that they will come for you.
And if they don't come for you, you're probably
the one coming for them.
This Thinkquisition will come after anyone
who bucks the trend and the stereotypes and
dares think for themselves.
It's why they come accuse Ayaan Hirsi Ali
of being anti muslim, it's why they slander
Bill Maher as a being racist, it's why they
call Larry Elder an uncle tom, and it's why
I can be branded a far right extremist.
Those who are a part of this Thinkquisition
fear you thinking for yourself, that you won't
bow to their collectivist demands, more than
anything else.
The way to beat this witch hunt is to be yourself,
and fight for what you believe.
You are the antidote they fear most.
I hope that next time you see me fighting
back and getting some cover from my allies,
it will inspire you to fight back... specifically
with words, not violence...
as well.
Joining me on the show this week is one of
my aforementioned allies and friends, author
and professor Peter Boghossian, who will help
me dissect the madness of 2017 and much more.